nval said you only sell because you
don't how to Market you only Market
because you don't know how to build a
product an exceptional product is a
quadratic relationship with your
audience good marketing or good sales is
a linear relationship meaning if I spend
a dollar I get X dollar back if I make X
phone calls I get y doll back but with a
product if you make an exceptional
product one person buys the product and
they tell two two tell four four tell
eight and so if you focus on the product
on making something that's so
unbelievable that people cannot help
themselves but tell other people about
it and you're like well how do I do that
you work on it and you keep working on
it and you don't make new products until
the first one's right